jetzt wollen wir erst uns noch ein video
anschauen heute hat nämlich auch der
prominente corinna leutner attila
hildmann sich zu wort gemeldet
er soll sich ja mit dem wendler
besprochen haben wir hören da jetzt
einfach mal kurz rein
wendel hat sich nicht positioniert
gesagt ich bin jetzt quasi attila
hildmann supporter warst einfach gesagt
was sache und ich bin quasi der
bekanntesten der händler der das regime
kritisiert und jetzt sagen sie alle weil
ich mit ihm telefoniert habe bin ich
daran letzten endes mitschuldig aber
letzten endes hat sich wenn ja schon
lange eine meinung gebildet darüber was
in diesem land passiert aber hast du mit
uns gesprochen nach dieser geschichte
und alltag wir reden regelmäßig okay